the state of Georgia has been cautiously
reopening for weeks now and so far this
isn't conclusive yet things seem much
better than the hysterics on Twitter
predicted a few states never locked down
at all and they're doing pretty well but
in Los Angeles the city that never
relatively speaking had a terribly
severe outbreak of the corona virus the
lockdown has now been extended through
the end of July so what is the
scientific basis for doing that that's
still not clear they never explained
likely because there isn't one millions
of people at little risk from
coronavirus meanwhile will be hurt by
this we know that for certain but we do
have and we're happy to end the show
tonight on some good news baseball may
soon be back Major League Baseball today
unveiled a plan to return in early July
before Los Angeles the downside is the
game should be held in empty stadiums
without fans if that plan is approved
the country would be a little closer to
normal and normal is what we want right
now every step back toward what we were
is a welcome step California inmates are
trying to use the corona virus to get
out of jail free choice Gallagher has
the very latest on that hey trace hey
Tucker this happened to the Castilla
Correctional Facility about 40 miles
northeast of Los Angeles where 30
inmates living in two separate dorms
have now tested positive for corona
virus when the outbreak began there was
an effort to track the origin and the
spread of the virus which prompted
prison authorities to go back and review
surveillance tapes and sure enough they
found images of what appeared to be
inmates trying to infect themselves with
kovin 19 in one video an inmate fills a
container with hot water and within a
minute three other inmates shared the
water some also put the water on their
foreheads to make it appear like they
had a fever other video shows inmates
sharing cups and bottles even sniffing a
mask that had already been worn Los
Angeles County Sheriff Alex Villanueva
says as a direct result of what was seen
in the video 21 men tested positive
watch somehow there was some mistaken
belief among the ma population if they
tested positive that there was a way to
force our hand and somehow release more
inmates out of our jail
Herman and that's not gonna happen
although the jails in Los Angeles County
typically has about 17 thousand inmates
and because of Kovan 19 there are now
fewer than 12,000 so the virus is
getting some sprung Tucker trace
Gallagher force thanks so much trace